Mais pour l'instant, vu que nous n'avons trouvé aucune trace
de nouveaux phénomènes,
on supposera que les particules que nous connaissons aujourd'hui,
dont le boson de Higgs,
sont les seules particules élémentaires dans la nature,
même à des énergies beaucoup plus grandes
que ce que nous avons explorées jusqu'à présent.
Voyons où cette hypothèse nous conduit.
Nous allons trouver un résultat surprenant et intriguant
concernant notre univers, et afin de bien me faire comprendre,
laissez-moi d'abord vous expliquer ce qu'est le boson de Higgs.
Pour cela, nous devons retourner
à un dixième de milliardième de seconde
après le Big Bang.
Selon la théorie de Higgs,
à ce moment-là, un événement spectaculaire s'est produit
dans l'univers.
L'espace-temps a subi une transition de phase.
Ça a été quelque chose de très similaire à la transition de phase
qui se produit lorsque l'eau se transforme en glace
en dessous de zéro degrés.
Mais dans notre cas, la transition de phase
n'est pas un changement dans la façon dont les molécules
sont arrangées dans la matière,
mais c'est un changement
du continuum même de l'espace-temps.
Pendant cette transition de phase,
l'espace vide s'est rempli d'une substance
que nous appelons maintenant le champ de Higgs.
Cette substance peut nous sembler invisible,
mais elle a une réalité physique.
Elle nous entoure tout le temps,
tout comme l'air que nous respirons dans cette salle.
Et certaines des particules élémentaires
réagissent avec cette substance en gagnant de l'énergie.
Cette énergie intrinsèque est ce que nous appelons
la masse d'une particule,
et en découvrant le boson de Higgs,
le LHC a prouvé que cette substance était réelle,
parce que c'est de ça dont les bosons de Higgs sont fait.
Voilà, en résumé, l'histoire de Higgs.
Mais l'histoire est bien plus intéressante que cela.
En étudiant la théorie de Higgs,
des physiciens théoriciens ont découvert,
non par une expérience,
mais grâce au pouvoir des mathématiques,
que le champ de Higgs pourrait ne pas exister uniquement
dans la forme que nous observons aujourd'hui.
Tout comme la matière peut exister à l'état liquide ou solide,
le champ de Higgs, la substance qui remplit tout l'espace-temps,
pourrait exister sous deux états.
En plus de l'état de Higgs que nous connaissons,
il pourrait y avoir un second état dans lequel le champ de Higgs
serait des milliards de milliards de fois plus dense
que ce que nous observons aujourd'hui,
et la simple existence d'un autre état du champ de Higgs
pose un problème potentiel.
Car selon les lois de la mécanique quantique,
il est possible
de passer d'un état à l'autre
même en présence d'une barrière d'énergie
séparant les deux états,
et ce phénomène est appelé
de manière plutôt pertinente, l'effet tunnel.
A cause de l'effet tunnel,
je pourrais disparaître de cette salle
et réapparaître dans la salle voisine,
en traversant quasiment le mur.
Mais ne vous attendez pas à ce que je réalise ce tour devant vos yeux,
parce que la probabilité
que je traverse le mur est ridiculement faible.
Il faudrait attendre très longtemps
avant que cela n'arrive, mais croyez-moi,
l'effet tunnel est un phénomène réel,
et il a été observé dans plusieurs systèmes.
Par exemple, le diode à effet tunnel,
un composant utilisé en électronique,
fonctionne grâce au miracle
de l'effet tunnel.
Mais revenons au champ de Higgs.
Si l'ultra-dense état de Higgs existe,
alors, à cause de l'effet tunnel,
une bulle de cet état pourrait soudainement apparaître
à un certain endroit de l'univers, à un certain moment,
un peu comme ce qui se passe lorsque vous faites bouillir de l'eau.
Des bulles de vapeur se forment dans l'eau,
puis s'agrandissent en transformant le liquide en gaz.
De la même façon, une bulle d'ultra-dense état de Higgs
pourrait apparaître à cause de l'effet tunnel.
La bulle se dilaterait alors à la vitesse de la lumière,
envahissant tout espace, et faisant passer le champ de Higgs
de l'état qu'on connait à un nouvel état.
Est-ce un problème ? Oui, c'est un gros problème.
Nous ne nous en rendons peut-être pas compte dans la vie quotidienne,
mais l'intensité du champ de Higgs est cruciale
pour la structure de la matière.
Si le champ de Higgs était seulement un peu plus intense,
nous verrions les atomes rétrécir, les neutrons se décomposer
au sein des noyaux atomiques, les noyaux se désintégrer
et l'hydrogène
serait le seul élément chimique possible dans l'univers.
Or le champ de Higgs, dans l'ultra-dense état de Higgs,
n'est pas seulement un peu plus intense qu'aujourd'hui,
mais des milliards de fois plus intense,
et si l'espace-temps était remplit par l'état de Higgs,
tout la matière atomique s'écroulerait.
Aucune structure moléculaire ne serait possible, aucune vie.
Donc, je m'interroge, est-il possible
que dans le futur, le champ de Higgs
subisse une transition de phase,
et, par effet tunnel, soit transformé
en ce méchant état ultra-dense ?
En d'autres mots, je me demande, quel est le destin
du champ de Higgs dans notre univers ?
L'ingrédient crucial nécessaire
pour répondre à cette question est la masse du boson de Higgs.
Les expériences au LHC ont montré
que la masse du boson de Higgs était d'environ 126 GeV.
C'est minuscule comparé aux unités courantes,
parce que c'est équivalent à quelque chose comme
10 puissance moins 22 grammes,
mais c'est gros comparé aux unités des particules élémentaires,
car c'est équivalent au poids
d'une molécule entière
d'un composant d'ADN.
Armés de cette information provenant du LHC,
avec quelques collègues ici, au CERN,
nous avons calculé la probabilité
que notre univers puisse emprunter l'effet tunnel
vers l'ultra-dense état de Higgs,
et nous avons trouvé un résultat très intriguant.
Nos calculs ont démontré
que la valeur mesurée de la masse du boson de Higgs
est très spéciale.
Elle a juste la valeur nécessaire
pour conserver l'univers en équilibre
dans une situation instable.
Le champ de Higgs est une configuration chancelante
qui a duré jusqu'à présent,
mais qui finira par s'écrouler.
Selon ces calculs,
nous sommes donc comme des campeurs
qui ont accidentellement monté leur tente
au bord d'une falaise.
Un jour ou l'autre, le champ de Higgs
subira une transition de phase
et la matière s'effondrera sur elle-même.
Est-ce ainsi que l'humanité disparaîtra ?
Je ne le pense pas.
Nos calculs montrent que l'effet tunnel
du champ de Higgs n'a pas de grande chance d'arriver
dans les prochaines 10 puissance 100 années,
ce qui est une durée très longue.
C'est même plus long
que le temps qu'il faut à l'Italie pour former un gouvernement stable.
(Rires)
Quoi qu'il en soit, nous serons partis depuis longtemps.
Dans environ 5 milliards d'années,
notre soleil deviendra une géante rouge,
aussi grosse que l'orbite de la Terre,
et notre planète sera kaputt.
Et dans mille milliards d'années,
si l'énergie noire continue d'alimenter
l'expansion de l'univers au même rythme qu'aujourd'hui,
vous ne pourrez même plus voir vos orteils,
parce que tout autour de vous
se dilaterait plus rapidement que la vitesse de la lumière.
Il est donc très peu probable
que nous soyons présents pour voir le champ de Higgs s'écrouler.
Mais la raison pour laquelle je m'intéresse
à la transition du champ de Higgs,
c'est que je veux examiner cette question :
pourquoi la masse du boson de Higgs est-elle si spéciale ?
Pourquoi est-elle juste parfaite pour garder l'univers
à la limite d'une transition de phase ?
Les physiciens théoriciens se demandent toujours "pourquoi ?"
Plutôt que "comment" un phénomène fonctionne,
les physiciens théoriciens s'intéressent toujours
à pourquoi un phénomène fonctionne de cette manière.
Nous pensons que ces "pourquoi"
peuvent nous donner des indices
concernant les principes fondamentaux de la nature.
Et en effet, une réponse possible à ma question
ouvre de nouveaux univers, littéralement.
Il a été imaginé que notre univers
était juste une bulle dans un multivers savonneux
fait d'une multitude de bulles,
et que chaque bulle était un univers différent,
avec des constantes fondamentales différentes,
et des lois physiques différentes.
Dans ce contexte, on peut seulement parler
de la probabilité de trouver une certaine valeur à la masse de Higgs.
Ainsi la clé du mystère
pourrait résider dans les propriétés statistiques
du multivers.
Ce serait quelque chose de similaire à ce qui se passe
avec les dunes de sable sur une plage.
En principe, on pourrait imaginer trouver des dunes de sable
avec des pentes de n'importe quel angle sur une plage,
et pourtant, l'angle d'inclinaison des dunes de sable
tourne habituellement autour de 30 à 35 degrés.
Et la raison en est simple :
le vent entasse le sable, la gravité le fait retomber.
Par conséquent, la grande majorité des dunes de sable
a un angle d'inclinaison qui tourne autour de la valeur critique
proche de l'écroulement.
Il pourrait se passer quelque chose de similaire
pour la masse du boson de Higgs dans le multivers.
Dans la majorité des bulles d'univers,
la masse de Higgs pourrait être égale à une valeur critique
proche d'un effondrement cosmique du champ de Higgs,
à cause de deux effets en concurrence,
exactement comme dans le cas du sable.
Mon histoire n'a pas de conclusion,
parce que nous ne connaissons toujours pas la fin de l'histoire.
Voilà ce qu'est la science en train de se faire,
pour résoudre le mystère, nous avons besoin de plus de données,
et, avec un peu de chance, le LHC apportera bientôt de nouveaux indices
à cette histoire.
Juste un nombre, la masse du boson de Higgs,
et déjà, de ce nombre, nous avons tant appris.
Je suis parti de l'hypothèse, qu'ils n'y a pas d'autres particules dans l'univers
que celles que nous connaissons déjà,
même au-delà du domaine exploré jusqu'à présent.
En partant de cela, nous avons découvert que le champ de Higgs,
qui s'infiltre dans l'espace-temps, se tient peut être
sur le fil du rasoir, prêt pour un effondrement cosmique,
et nous avons découvert que cela pourrait indiquer
que notre univers n'est qu'un grain de sable
sur une plage géante, le multivers.
Mais je ne sais pas si mon hypothèse est juste.
C'est comme ça que la physique fonctionne : une simple mesure
peut nous mettre sur la voie d'une nouvelle façon
de concevoir l'univers,
ou peut nous envoyer droit dans un cul-de-sac.
Mais, quoi qu'il advienne,
il y a une chose dont je suis sûr :
le voyage sera plein de surprises.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)